in airport having flown in to balmoral  to see the queen this is a replay of the  pictures we saw just a few moments ago a  prince harry  leaving scotland  he happened to be  on a trip to europe and to this country  with his wife when news came from the  palace that there were concerns about  the queen's hell so he was able to  travel to scotland a lot quicker than he  would have done from his home in america  he was the last to arrive the queen's  children  and  him and his brother prince harry and his  brother prince william all arrived at  balmoral yesterday afternoon  once the news had come through he was  the last to arrive and it appears that  he's the first to leave barbara as well  they're getting on a plane at aberdeen  airport to make his way  away